this year's billionaires list has 2
668 billionaires from 75 countries or
territories spread across six continents
following last year's record-breaking
number of billionaires the past 12
months have proven to be more volatile a
total of 329 people dropped off the list
this year the most in a single year
since the 2009 financial crisis
regionally asia pacific boasts the most
billionaires with 1088 followed by the
united states with 735 and europe with
592.
the us remains the leading country for
billionaires with eight of the 10
richest people in the world altogether
america's billionaires are worth 4.7
trillion dollars of course it's led by
the world's number one richest person
elon musk who's worth an estimated 219
billion dollars
china is the country with the second
most billionaires
539 billionaires collectively worth two
trillion dollars
india the country with the third most
billionaires added 26 people to the
three comma club this year and number
four is germany they have 134
billionaires worth a collective 608
billion dollars
at number five is russia president
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine and
the swift backlash of the international
community sent russian markets into a
free fall in february there are 34 fewer
russian billionaires this year as share
prices cratered the ruble plummeted in
value and sanctions hit russian
oligarchs assets
the collective wealth of the country's
billionaires has fallen from 584 billion
last year to 320 billion this year
some of the biggest losers include oil
magnate vegetarov and alexi mordechov
previously the richest person in russia
some of the additions to the list
include taiwan which jumped into the top
10 this year thanks to four new
billionaires and four countries that did
not have a billionaire last year now
have at least one citizen on the forbes
list uruguay estonia bulgaria and
barbados which now has one very famous
face on the ranking
you